given the relative molecular scales if
the Nano kids held the world cup
tournament would they be able to use
buckyballs to play or would it end up
like the big ball soccer please see the
quirky cartoon posted on all in his blog
but I haven't been able to do that well
I think they would I think c60 does roll
around and it should be possible to play
some form of game with c60 on a surface
and it would be interesting because it
will happen is sufficiently small that
it might have quantum behavior and it
would be quite interesting to to see
where the one could play quantum
football or quantum American football or
in fact baseball or cricket whether it
would spin and what the spin might be
and basketball with with a c16 molecule
and I think it could be possible in the
future I mean we'd have to have improve
our scanning tunneling microscopy you
know atomic force microscopy techniques
but I think that's all the cars